tout nu connu c'est la manière des
naturistes manière de voir manière de
vivre ses vacances
il est vrai que la première fois il
arrive certainement ça bouge de
réticences du fait de notre culture
française la fille du duo chrétienne et
serra 7 en 1949 entre cette plage
déserte et une forêt calcinée par les
bombardements qu'est né le premier
centre naturiste harmoniser sa vie avec
les rythmes de la nature vivre nu en
collectivité dans le respect des hôtels
en sont les principes fondamentaux
c'est toute une philosophie de vie et
l'oubli des différences sociales mais
tous au même au même diapason on regarde
pas la différence sur une personne qui
peut avoir un maillot un maillot de
grands couturiers ou un maillot acheté
dans une grande surface
ici c'est un peu comme une grande
famille 12 collective jeu de boules
promenade sous les chênes toutes sortes
d'activités qui ont beaucoup intéressé
les voyeurs metulla ça c'est une
sculpture c'est du moulin sur corps
comble de l'hédonisme chez les
naturistes et eux ils appellent cela un
souvenir de vacances